- Good afternoon and good evening,
depending on your location,
I'm Saad Omer,
the Director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health.
I'm really delighted to welcome you
to the 'Global Health Conversation Series'
sponsored by and led by
the Yale Institute for Global Health
and as a lot of you know,
already that the series is a venue
for the Yale community
and beyond to learn from
and connect with innovative
leaders in global health.
In addition to YIGH, we are
grateful for the Walker Fund
by the McMillan Center at Yale
for co-sponsoring the series
including today's event,
it's a pleasure to be all of you today.
As you know the world faces
unprecedented challenges
of humanitarian crises in
more than 2000 countries
resulting from armed
conflicts, natural disasters.
These are being accelerated and multiplied
by the global climate change
and the ongoing COVID-19 global pandemic.
These emergencies have significant
impact on global health,
including increased death
illness and disability.
In addition to that, the
economic cost of course,
of these crises are enormous.
So, found at the call of
Albert Einstein in 1933,
the International Rescue Committee,
so I guess no pressure on their leaders
to stand up to this legacy.
And so International
Rescue Committee's mission
is to help the world's
most vulnerable people
whose lives and livelihoods
have been shattered
by conflict and disaster,
including the climate crisis
and to help them survive,
recover and regain control
of their future.
And so IRC delivers lasting
impact by providing healthcare
and engaging in activities
that help children learn
and empower individuals
to become self reliant
in these kinds of situations.
And so to discuss how we
sustain health and wellbeing
in the face of disaster,
we are pleased to have with us today
David Miliband the
President and CEO of IRC.
Since 2013, Mr. Miliband has overseen
the agency's operations in
40 crisis conflict countries
and its refugees resettlement
and in assistance program
throughout Europe and the Americas.
Prior to joining the IRC,
he has had a distinguished
political career in the UK
from 2007 to 2010 for example,
he served as the 74th Secretary of State
for Foreign and Commonwealth Affairs,
in short, often referred to
as the UK Foreign Secretary,
if I'm not mischaracterizing it
and representing the UK
throughout the world.
His accomplishments have
earned him a reputation
in former President Bill Clinton's words,
"As one of the ablest most creative
public servants of our time."
And in 2016, Mr. Milliband was named
one of the World's Greatest Leaders
by 'Fortune Magazine'
and in 2018, he was inducted
to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences
and those of you who
have gone to that place,
it's quite a legacy to be inducted
in the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
it has acceptance letters
from Charles Darwin,
I think Thomas Jefferson himself
if I'm not misremembering,
but at least a few of those individuals
who have contributed to
this country and beyond
in meaningful ways, so
he's in good company there.
He's an author of the book,
'Rescue: Refugees and the
Political Crisis of Our Time.'
As a son of refugees,
David, if I may call
you by your first name
brings a personal
commitment to the IRCs work
and to the premise of the book
that we can rescue the
dignity and hopes of refugees
and displaced people
and if we help them in the process,
we will rescue rescue our own values.
Welcome David and it's a
pleasure to have you here.
- Thanks very much, indeed,
it's really good to be with you
and I'm looking forward
to the conversation
and the questions.
- Wonderful, so just to prime the pump
and give you an opportunity
to sort of broadly outline
some of the things.
So what is the scope and scale
of the humanitarian crises
we are grappling with
around the globe right now?
As I said, the IRC was founded
by Albert Einstein in 1933,
how does this era compare to other eras
in the history of IRC?
- Thanks very much for having me speak
to this distinguished group
and distinguished audience.
Look, we've just published
our emergency watch list for 2022
and this covers the 20
countries that we think
will be the epicenter
of humanitarian crisis for the year ahead.
The population of these 20 countries
is about 800 million people,
in other words, 10% of
the global population,
but these 20 countries account
for about 80% of the people,
90% of the people in humanitarian need,
including 80 or 90% of
the number of refugees,
internally displaced,
civilians killed in conflict.
So, in those 20 countries,
there are about 275 million people
who are in need of humanitarian aid
led by a country like Afghanistan,
where 22 million people
are currently dependent
on the World Food Program
for their next meal.
And these are countries
marked by a number of factors,
many of which are different from before,
so obviously Einstein set up the IRC
in advance of the Second World War.
We now see that refugees
and humanitarian need
is generally, we obviously
all holding our breath
about the Russia-Ukraine situation,
but generally we are dealing
with wars within the states,
not wars between states,
there are actually no hot wars
between states at the moment
pending what happens
in Ukraine and Russia.
There are 55 civil wars going on,
so-called civil wars
going on at the moment,
eight of them classified as severe
because they have more than a
thousand battlefield deaths.
Afghanistan, as I said, top of the list
for the war that's finished there,
but Ethiopia, Yemen high on the list.
The second point that's different
from certainly the origins of the IRC
is that the most likely
consequence of a civil war
is a further war.
The duration of conflict is extending,
the tools of diplomacy are weak
for dealing with civil wars,
the tools of diplomacy were
developed for negotiations
between states, not for
resolving war within states
and the duration of displacement
of need is becoming chronic
rather than just acute to
use health terminology.
I suppose the third
element that's striking
about the numbers of people in need
is that half of them
are under the age of 18,
two-thirds of them are women and girls,
so there's a strong gender
dimension to the structure
and geography of poverty
and of humanitarian need,
so I think that's
important to flag as well.
Now these factors lead us
in our emergency watch list
to say that there's
system failure going on,
states are failing in
their responsibilities
to their own citizens,
diplomacy is failing,
'cause there are 55 civil war still going.
The legal regime is failing
because rights to life
and livelihood are being circumvented,
impunity is the order of the day
and the humanitarian aid system
is struggling to catch up.
So that's the picture
that we are dealing with,
that's why we are now a
billion dollar organization
with probably about 35,
37,000 staff of employees
and day workers around the world,
why we've hired another
thousand people in Afghanistan
in the last three months.
And just to round out the picture,
we're a $1 billion organization
in a 40, 41 billion dollar
sector of the global economy,
which is called the
Humanitarian Aid sector
and as we may discuss sits
in rather separate stovepipe
from the development sector
where much global health
provision has made progress
in the last 20 years
and where some of the
problems that are most acute
can be squarely seen in the
failure of these two systems
to work with each other.
So I hope that gives you a picture.
- No, that's interesting to say the least,
the fact that the need is such...
That the sector is active and growing,
but also the whole that
there is this safety net
to mitigate the impact
of the system failure
that you described.
So, getting to a little bit of more...
One of the specific areas of interest
that actually I personally
have, I work on vaccines
as part of my sort of
a major focus of work,
a lot of these situations result
in disruption of immunization efforts
and as I understand IRC
has worked with partners
to sort of bridge that gap
in some of these populations.
So what is the state
of vaccination efforts
in countries where the IRC operates
what are some of the key challenges
and what would it take to bridge that gap?
- Yeah, well, look there are two parts
of the answer to that question,
I think one is as if we were
having this conversation
two years ago
and then there's the answer
in the wake of COVID,
so let me address separately.
Most of the places we work
either have no effective health system
or a very weak health system
sometimes marked by conflict
between the governing
authorities of the places we work
and the national authorities.
So in the democratic Republic of Congo
during the Ebola crisis,
health centers were being attacked
because they were perceived
to be an imposition
of the central government
and the international
agencies were seen as allies
of the central government
in opposition to local
or political opposition
in the in Eastern Kivu and or
in the east of the country.
And this were raises a
very interesting point,
there was really quite
spectacular progress
towards the Millennium Development Goals
that were enunciated in 2000
people talked in 2015
about being halfway there.
And the problem is the
second half of the match
to provide global health coverage
is completely different than
the first half of the match,
because the first for the match
was about health system strengthening,
whereas the second half of the match
is well, what you do when
really it's a much more
conflicted situation?
And it's very hard to
think about a system,
there isn't yet a system
and that's where we have been working
and where we've tried
to break out of the idea
that we are just the "emergency" sector
that we are there when
people fall down off a cliff,
people use this cliche,
we should build fences
at the top of cliffs,
not just to help people
at the bottom of cliffs,
that's wrong increasingly
for the places we work,
because there are chronic problems
not just disaster of
someone falling off a cliff.
Now, the COVID crisis has both
fed off those inequalities
and exacerbated those inequalities,
I mean, the basic answer to your question,
what's the vaccine situation
in the places that you work?
I mean, there basically
aren't any vaccines,
I mean, that's more or less the situation,
I mean, it's the most stupid
piece of short termism
on the part of the global community,
not to have global vaccination,
I don't need to have the rhetoric on that,
I'm sure you've got the
facts to back it up,
but essentially it's the fog of war
when it comes to fighting COVID
in the places that we work
'cause there isn't proper testing,
so no one really knows who's got it.
And there isn't proper vaccination
and in the first year of the crisis,
there was very weak
public health measures.
I mean, there are information campaigns,
but there's a lot of disinformation,
there are attempts to
promote hand washing,
there isn't enough water you
know the story quite well.
There's probably a overmedicalization
of the idea of health
when, of course pandemics require
thought and action
beyond the health sector.
I'm not sure if I'm allowed to say that
in the Yale Institute
of Global Public Health,
but that's the two answer
that I would give to your question.
- No, no, you're absolutely right
and one of the things
that we do here at YIGH
at the Yale Institute for Global Health
is go beyond the traditional
biomedical assets
that you bring that you
bring to these problems
because we know that if
global health solutions
are only draw from a
limited number of fields,
you always almost invariably fall short
and it's not just true for pandemics
or sort of displaced
populations, et cetera.
It's true for HIV and
noncommunicable diseases
and all of that stuff, but
you're absolutely right.
So you alluded to that and
you have previously described
and you've used the term,
"the age of impunity"
specifically in the context of attacks
on healthcare workers, et cetera.
And there was like sort
of you miss something
when you don't have it,
there used to be maybe obviously,
the past looks rosier than it's often is,
but doesn't it seem and I
think you were alluding to that
that it's more of direct
attacks on healthcare workers,
at least that perception is there
and so how do we get back to
at least what was there before
or at least a better normal
in that kind of a situation,
and you are uniquely positioned
because of your political
background in there.
And so how do we get back to that
sort of unsaid packed
between various players?
- Well, I think first of all,
we recognize that the
fact that it was unsaid
was a weakness and not a strength.
- Yeah.
- And essentially the bargain post 1945,
was that in parallel or in
addition to the rights of states,
there'd be rights of individuals,
universal human rights
and when I talk about the age of impunity,
what I refer to is the
abrogation of those rights.
Impunity as you know,
is actions without consequence,
crimes without punishment
and when it comes to
attacks on health workers,
you've got a classic case
of rights to livelihood
and civilian protection in conflict,
but then being abrogated
by conflict players.
I mean, Syria is the most infamous example
where attacks on health facilities
actually increased after a UN
Security Council Resolution
that condemned attacks on health workers
and called for them to cease.
So, you can see the impunity
in the thumbing of the nose,
again, in the face of the UN
Security Council Resolution.
Obviously, this requires us to think
not just about a humanitarian
answer, but a political answer
because every humanitarian
crisis is a political crisis
to every humanitarian emergency
is a political emergency.
And in the launch of our
emergency watch list this year,
I talked about the humanitarian sector,
but I also ventured into geopolitics
to say that we had a
responsibility to bear witness
to what was happening
and call out the failure
of the international system
to uphold its own norms
and then to suggest ways
that they could be upheld.
Let me just give you one interesting,
I think, example of this
in the interest of not
and I could speak for the
next 40 minutes about this,
so I won't.
So at the moment, the veto
in the UN Security Council,
which is held by five countries,
US obviously, UK, France,
China, and Russia,
the only veto wielding countries
reflecting the balance
of power after 1945,
there is a French proposal
that the veto should be suspended
in cases of mass atrocity.
Now, that is one way of
shifting the dice a bit
in favor of the civilians
who are meant to be having
protections under the UN Charter.
That's not an answer and
it probably won't happen,
but it's the kind of thing
that would actually shift
the balance of power.
'Cause at the moment to
state the obvious, I suppose,
impunity reflects imbalance of power
and you have to have a
countervailing power,
Galbraith it called a countervailing power
to push against that.
Now, to the extent that shame doesn't work
as countervailing power,
to the extent that economic sanction
doesn't work as countervailing power,
to the extent that
arming opposition groups,
which some countries do
doesn't work as countervailing power,
you need to get to the root
of the imbalance of power,
which is essentially the conflict actors,
think they've got protection,
as a protection racket for
their attacks on health workers.
And that's what I think
one has to understand
is the root of this problem
and it needs to be called out.
And obviously the Syrian example
allows those of us in the Western world
to blame the Russians and the Iranians
and the Syrian government.
But the Yemen example,
I'm afraid it plays the other way
where Saudi led coalition, which
includes the US and the UK,
hasn't been targeting health
workers in the same way,
but as you probably
know 43 kids got killed
in a coach load in Northern Yemen,
which is also as close to a
war crime as you can imagine.
So, those in glass houses
have got to be careful
about throwing stones and there are...
I don't want to draw
equivalence between if you like
the authoritarian autocratic
parts of the world
and the democratic parts of the world,
'cause again that's a grievous mistake,
but I don't want to seem
blind to the failings
or to the mistakes that have been made
on "our side" as well.
- Oh, that's interesting
and the fact that you
mentioned this a political
sort of initiative to address this.
If I can say so in our
institutions there...
My colleagues can be fairly
loud for the right course,
so I'm sure you'll find allies
and I know that-
- But I would love you
to be loud.
I mean, there's essentially
impunity thrives on darkness
and on quietude and essentially
the 70% of victims in war today
are of are civilians not soldiers.
- Yeah, absolutely and so
if you need more voices
and voice is something
that needs to be amplified
by sort of actors and advocates,
especially health workers,
but not exclusively.
So feel free to send it our way
and you would be happy to as an aside,
circulate that.
- Thank you.
And so another aspect that has...
I'm not exaggerating if I would say
that it's a near existential threat
or if not an existential
threat, is the climate crisis
and actually for vulnerable communities,
it is an existential threat.
So in your work, how have
you seen climate change
affect how conflicts occur and unfold
and not just the number of conflicts,
but the nature of conflicts
and specially going forward?
- Yeah, I mean, this is an area
where it's easy to be glib,
but also easy to be wrong.
I mean, a lot of people
talk about climate refugees
and that doesn't yet fit the facts.
I mean, we've got a lot of climate IDPs
internally displaced people,
but not that many people who
cross international borders
as a result of climate crisis,
although you can imagine that happening.
You asked about climate and conflict
and I see this in a couple of ways.
One is that obviously the climate crisis
contributes to resource stress
and resource stress is one
of the drivers of conflict,
so you've got an indirect impact there.
Secondly, there's no question
that some of the people
that we serve notably in
the Sahel, but not only
you'll know well that
there is Syria Scholarship
about how the climate
crisis in Northwestern Syria
was a contributor to the
flow of people to the cities
in 2008, 2011 and that contributed
to the Syrian uprising,
I don't want to opine on that here.
But there's no question that a good number
of the communities that we serve
have done very little to
contribute to the climate crisis,
but are on the receiving end
of its pernicious effects
and they move or they are impoverished.
And one of the things that we
are doing now is building...
We rewrote our strategy
a year and a half ago
and we now talk about the climate crisis
clearly as a driver of humanitarian need.
In our watch list of a year ago,
not the most recent, but the one before,
we talked about conflict climate and COVID
as the drivers of humanitarian need
and that obviously remains
significantly the case.
There's more scholarship to be done
about exactly how that follows through
into migratory patterns,
but it's obvious that
it's going to be real,
although to emphasize,
I think it's more likely
to be an IDP issue,
an internal displacement issue
of which there are about just
so your audience may know
there's about 35 million refugees
and asylum seekers around the world,
those are people who've
left their own country
as a result of effectively politics,
as opposed to economics.
But there's 45 million people
who are internally displaced
as a result of conflict
and related issues,
Syria being a prime example
both of refugee flows
and of IDP flows.
And obviously we see, we fear,
we anticipate the climate crisis
as a conflict multiplier, if you like.
- Yeah, so in terms of the kinds of things
communities can do around the world,
like our community here in New Haven,
anything specific that
communities like New Haven can do
our host town for this university
to support refugee communities,
we are again, a center where
a lot of refugee settlement
is happening, including
in the recent crisis,
but what are some of the things
that individual communities
can do to help out with these crises?
- Well, the IRC is a good organization
to ask that question to,
because we work across the arc of crisis,
we're an international
humanitarian aid agency,
but we're also a refugee
resettlement agency
in 25 US cities,
we're the largest refugee
resettlement agency in America
and I like to point out we're
actually the number one rated,
which is the more important
than being the largest.
Now, sadly, we're not allocated
the office in New Haven
and I'm not sure whether
it's Catholic Charities
or the Lutheran World Service
or HIAS, the Hebrew Immigrant Aid Society
that is the lead agency in New Haven.
But President Biden has said
he wants to increase
from 15,000 to 125,000,
the number of refugees let
into America every year,
this was before the Afghan crisis.
People don't know this,
but Ronald Reagan let him more refugees
than any other American president
after the 1980 Refugee Act
was passed under President Carter.
And I'm afraid President
Trump ran the program
almost into the ground
down to 12,000 refugees.
President Biden said he
would increase it to 125,000,
it'll take a year or two to do that.
But then we've got the
70,000 Afghans who arrived
and there will be Afghans
arriving in New Haven,
just like there will be
Congolese or South Sudanese
or Rohingya from Myanmar.
And what those people need is the services
of resettlement agencies,
but they also need buddies,
they also need English teachers,
they also need people to explain to them
how the American healthcare system works.
And I can say very strongly to you,
even though we don't work in New Haven,
it's not one of the places
that we are allocated
by the state department,
there's a lot for you to do there.
I'm actually in London at the moment,
that's why I've got this
beautiful background
that you can see from this
rather Spartan Hotel room.
But I was meeting some refugees
that we are resettling here
in the Southeast of England
this morning from
Afghanistan and from Syria
and they need cultural orientation
when you've gone through
the trauma of displacement
is a massive thing.
And so you can do good locally,
as well as using the
extraordinary platform of Yale
to reach out globally.
I mean, reaching out globally,
we are the largest
impact evaluation agency
in the humanitarian sector
and we do work with you,
we could probably do more about what works
in humanitarian circumstances,
we have something called
the Outcomes and Evidence Framework,
that you can see online,
which is what our country directors see.
So you can do more
through your professional
responsibilities.
And then as you were saying earlier,
there's your voice both
individually and collectively
because the COVID crisis has shown
that even when disaster
is staring global leaders
in the face, they can
avoid the responsibility
of tending the global comments
and that I think should
be extremely worrying
whether you're in the humanitarian sector
or in the health sector.
- Absolutely, so switching
gear gears a little bit,
but you played a role
in the Independent Panel
for Pandemic Preparedness and Response,
it was perfectly involved
through my next door neighbor
Ernesto Zedillo-
- Oh, wow.
- Who's a faculty member
here at Yale as well
and the panel prepared a very interesting
and insightful report,
but this was around the time
that the report came out in early 2021,
this was pre-Delta, it was
around Alpha and now Omicron
and it was around the
time when we had the hope
and somewhat some would say
that the naive illusion,
that low income countries
will get the vaccines fairly quickly.
So things have changed since then
and so any thoughts about,
like in addition to bearing witness
to this enormous strategy,
what are the prospects of
some of the recommendations
and feel free to highlight
any specific recommendations-
- So look, let me talk about the panel
and what it said and to
what it's been ignored
and then let me talk
also on the same page,
the International Panel on
Pandemic Preparedness Response
was set up by the World Health Assembly,
it was independent,
it was chaired by two
former prime ministers,
Helen Clark and Ellen Johnson Sirleaf.
It had about 15 people who
included experts in health,
but was not dominated by health experts
and the fundamental
insight was that pandemics
are not a health issue, they
are a health and security
and politics and economic issue.
And the recommendations
spoke to that central point
that pandemic control
required political leadership
at the highest level,
it needed additional
funding through health
but also non-health institutions,
it required a commitment to equity.
And there was a set of
structural recommendations
for the World Health
Organization, but also beyond it,
because our argument was
that if everything gets left
to the WHO, it won't get done,
because it goes beyond health.
Now, what we got wrong I think,
or what was a tactical error,
is our recommendations,
whether about PPE or production facilities
or intellectual property
were about future pandemic.
What we should have recognized
is that what we need
in terms of preparing ourselves
and responding to future pandemics,
we actually need now for
the current pandemic.
And we had recommendations
for the current pandemic,
but they were separate
from the recommendations
for the future.
What strikes me is that, we
were published in May, 2021,
so the it's not quite a year,
but the health machinery through
the World Health Assembly
and the negotiating machinery there,
doesn't have the political
sway to deliver the money
and the political accountability
that pandemic preparedness
and response requires
and so we've got a
mismatch between the places
that are negotiating
internationally on this
and the places that have real power.
Now, President Biden and
his team to be fair to them,
they've held One Leader Level Summit,
they're having another one in March
to try to break out of this conundrum
that the health infrastructure
for negotiation takes years
and we haven't got yours on our side.
But you'll know that the
US is also quite conflicted
about the WHO and the
WHO is two-third funded
by voluntary contributions.
That's not a basis for a
sustainable independence of mind
and we argued very strongly that the WHO
needed to be more independent
and more powerful to hold
countries to account.
And I think it's a real
struggle at the moment,
hopefully the next summit
that President Biden holds
will help address the current crisis
and in the process help
prepare us for the next one,
because you'll know this better than I,
but my reading suggests
we got lucky with Omicron
and it could easily have
been more transmissible
than Delta but also more virulent
and we've got off in some sense slightly.
- Yeah, and there's no
guarantee that a variant
that is more transmissible
will have lower virulence
that seems to be a misconception
that there's some sort of magic trade off
that the virus makes with itself...
And sort of evolutionary
biology has told us
that no, that doesn't have to be the case
in these kinds of situations.
So, I'm now taking one
question from the audience
and the first question from there is,
how do you think today's change
in the liberal world order
as compared to when it
was first established
and you can add nuance,
when was the prime of
the liberal world order?
It never a sort of a
perfect moment for that,
but let's suppose that
the current situation
has seen changes and emergence of players
that are decidedly illiberal
in the sort of nonpartisan
sense of the world.
And how would that change
humanitarian efforts
in public health?
- Well, I think first of all,
it's really important that we don't fall
into a sort of golden ageism,
the cold war was not a golden
age for obvious reasons.
Secondly, I do think
without wishing to fall
into being panglosian about it,
there was a period in
the early two thousands,
it was a brief shining moment
when ideas of global
responsibility really took root.
It wasn't a product just
of the end of the cold war,
it was a product of the failings in Rwanda
and in former Yugoslavia
and that led to this period
where there was a real
discussion up until 2006
about international responsibilities
and the extent to which state sovereignty
was an insufficient
basis on which to manage
an interdependent world order.
And I prefer to talk
about a rules-based order
rather than a liberal international order.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think that
liberal is too complicated
for too many people, I
mean, just as a digression,
that if you remember what
I said 20 minutes ago,
about rights for individuals,
that is the essence of a liberal ideal
that individuals have have rights.
But sometimes when we talk about
liberal international order,
we lose side the fact
that it was about rules
that would govern the powerful
and try to protect the powerless.
Now, how do the changes
that we've seen affect...
The question was
particularly about health.
I think there are two
things to say about that,
one is back to don't throw stones
if you're in a glass house.
I mean, iliberalism I
don't need to tell you
the attack on rules-based systems
I mean, I work in New York
but I'm British citizen,
both of our countries
have suffered attacks
on their own rule of law recently
and that is a trend
across the industrialized democratic world
that the rules-based order
is being poorly defended
by the world's democratic states,
which are a minority of states
and certainly and a small
minority of the global population
live in fully democratic societies.
And Fareed Zakaria wrote 20 years ago
about the rise of illiberal democracy.
So we've gotta tend to our own houses
and actually just in parenthesis,
the Biden administration's approach
to the Russia-Ukraine crisis
has actually been an assertion
of democratic strength
in the face of an assault
on the rules-based order,
by a leading autocratic country.
The second thing though,
is where and how to combat the assault
on the rules-based order
from those who don't want
to live by rules at home,
in the autocratic world.
And here there's a real push and pull
because on the one hand,
the Chinese leadership fear
instability on the other hand,
they don't want to have
their own power curbed
and I think this speaks to very much
the agenda of the liberal democratic world
standing together in a very clear way,
not to invent new rules,
but to defend old rules
that all countries have signed
because by signing the UN Charter,
all countries have signed up to
a basic set of human rights
and that has to be fought over
and that's about politics in the end.
- And I think I'm glad
that you went there,
you went to not just sort of people
not playing by the rules if you will
at the interstate level,
but sort of between states
in terms of between state dynamics,
but also domestically and
that is frankly something
that worries some of us a little bit more,
the things that you took
for grant are under threat.
And so extending that
conversation a little bit,
because there are actors,
both state-based and non-state actors
that now in this interconnected world
that has the power for major disruption
and as I understand, ICRC recently saw
in terms of breach of
data of vulnerable people
and I understand that coming
from a question recently
and you feel free to correct me
if this information is inaccurate
by a malicious cyber actor,
what does the humanitarian
sector need to do?
- Oh, that's interesting.
ICRC, just so everyone knows
is the international committee on the-
- Yeah, no, not you guys.
Not you guys.
- Not us guys (chuckles).
if you're a donor don't worry,
we're keeping your stuff safe.
- Yeah, no.
- Now, let just say one thing about that-
- So the question came
for the broader sector.
- Yeah, I understand, here's
a really interesting point-
- Yeah.
- All the pressure in our sectors
to spend less on "administration."
- Yeah.
- But good administration
means protecting data
of clients as well as supporters
and you gotta spend on that.
Spending on cybersecurity
is almost bad spending
in the way some of the charity watchdogs
and others work on this.
Any organization that says
it doesn't spend anything
on administration
means it's not spending
anything on cybersecurity
and that can't be sensible.
So, I could answer the
question at great length,
but I think just the most
basic thing to say is,
what's the responsibility
of the humanitarian sector,
is the responsibility to tell
the truth that this costs
and it's a good investment.
- Yeah, no I agree and not
all administrative costs
are created equal.
Sometimes what is charge
at administrative costs
increases the efficiency
of the direct costs
of individual projects and initiatives
and I think all of us
need to do a better job,
including academic to communicate that,
that this money can be very well utilized
and sort of mitigate a
lot of substantial risks.
And so there's this interesting question,
at least I find it interesting
I think from a postdoctoral
fellow who has a small gun-
- Oh my God, there's no way
I can match this brain power.
- So, she talks about a small grant
she got to aid the general
health of Afghan people
recently resettled in Oklahoma City.
And if you had to...
She's taking an opportunity to ask you,
if you had to she has a small grant
and has a sort of a focus area,
but some flexibility
to where to spend this
and how to spend this.
If you had to pick one
health problem to focus on
obviously difficult because
there a lot of things that...
This is a difficult question
because there are a lot of
things that are important,
would you go to the psychosocial
and mental health promotion
or a physical health intervention
in Afghan refugee population
in this moment in time
in an American city?
- Well, we don't actually
work in Oklahoma,
but we work across the country.
I'll tell you what I would
guess we would spend it on
and then I'll explain
why I use the word guess.
I would guess we would decide
to spend it on mental health,
because I know that significant numbers
of the Afghan arrivals
are deeply traumatized
by their survival and the fact
they've left people behind.
The reason I say guess is very important,
because the right answer if I may say so,
so the question is, I'd ask the clients,
I mean, it's a big part of our approach
that our needs assessments are
not done by people like me,
they're done by human-centered designers
who are talking to clients
and assessing need.
And so I hope that the grant
giver who are question...
Obviously, I hope they'll
give us the grant,
although in Oklahoma I suppose they can't.
But the best answer I think,
surely is to say, you'd
have to ask the people
and test with the people.
My instinct is that the proximate need
is more likely to be greater
on the mental health side
than on the physical health side,
but I'd want to cover myself by saying
that's only a guess and
I'd want to really test it
with the population.
- Interesting, so the next...
And I think it's in line
with sort of the ethos
of a community-based public health,
you ask the population, you do the work
using tools like (indistinct) and others.
And so the next question
actually comes from
the Dean of our School of
Public Health here at Yale,
Sten Vermund and his question
is that IRC is famous,
very famous for its region to regions
of the most acute need.
And what are the strategies
that you're using now,
in supporting and rebuilding
healthcare systems
when political systems
are very unsupported.
So for example, Syria,
Myanmar or somewhat paralyzed
like Haiti, Yemen, and Congo,
where the intention perhaps at least
a lot of the intention is there,
but capability is not there
because public health
101 is get the buy in
from the government and
the governed, et cetera,
but when you don't have that
and sometimes they're antagonistic,
so how do you solve that conundrum?
- Well, we do health
system strengthening work
in partnership with local governments
or national governments
where they are willing to work with us.
But in places like Northwest
Syria or elsewhere,
the national government is oppositional
and the local authorities are non-state
and so we're in exactly the bind,
the Dean of your school and
he's probably got a better
or she's got a better
answer than I have to this.
But the kind of things I
would talk about are one,
the information on war really matters
and disinformation and misinformation
is the first enemy of
effective public health.
And we as trusted partners
of local communities
we can work well
in tackling misinformation
and disinformation.
Secondly, you will know better than I
that a lot of community-based care
can achieve far more per dollar
than health center or hospital-based care.
So the second thing we've got four
research and innovation priorities
one is about sexual and
reproductive health,
maternal and newborn health
and it's very much focused on self care.
We have a second research
and innovation priority
around malnutrition,
the current system for a
severe acute malnutrition
is separate from moderate,
acute malnutrition
and it depends on people
getting to health centers,
which in South Sudan, they're
not gonna make it there.
So again, you build from
the community level,
the diagnosis and
treatment at a local level.
Thirdly, an important part of our work now
is to work with non-state partners
as well as state partners,
community based organizations,
that's an important way of winning trust,
but also extending scale.
Now that doesn't quite count
as building a health system,
which was the Dean's answer,
I dunno whether you can mic him or her up
to say what would be a better answer,
because I'm obviously far less
of an expert than him or her.
But those are the kind of
things that we are trying to do
to sustain a web of health interventions
below the secondary care level,
which is frankly not where we do the work.
- Wonderful, so let's see if we can add
Sten to the panel and if he is
able to join from that side.
One thing that you might wanna
and I wanted to keep that for the end,
but I don't wanna forget about it
because we have a lot of questions.
So you'd love to hear
this, one of the comments,
it says not a question,
but I do wanna say thank you to IRC
for doing an amazing job
and I thought of just
a blanket appreciation
because this person is a
former refugee from Rwanda
and with support from IRC,
they were able to restart their
life here in the US in 2000
and they're now soon to be a student
at Yale School of Public Health.
- Wow, that's fantastic.
- Isn't that gratifying?
- That's fantastic, really heartwarming
and if he or she writes to
me, sends to me an email
I'd love to find out about their story.
I mean, look I think
we are now the large...
I think I've said this, the
largest impact evaluation agency
in the humanitarian sector
and that's 'cause we go
to places that people
aren't used to studying what really works,
but we think it matters even
more in emergency situations
to use the money well and
to use right approaches
and when you hear a story
like the one I you you've just
said, that's really great.
- Wonderful.
So I got a message that
says Sten has been promoted
and when faculty hear this news,
it usually whether they got
tenure or became full professor,
but Sten is already a seasoned
public health professional
this essentially means that he's here
on the Zoom panel side.
So Sten, do you wanna sort
of add to what David said?
- Give a better answer than I gave?
- Well, thank you very much,
I wasn't expecting to speak
but David your response about the pivoting
from national partners to local partners
and community partners,
I think that is very insightful
and really gets to the point
that I was thinking you might make
because I've connected to
IRC even as a young man
with some of the nature of
the work of your organization
and I feel that when we have circumstances
that might look to professionals or donors
or purses of goodwill as almost hopeless.
The Rohingya in central Myanmar
driven from their homes,
Syria, circumstances in Eastern Congo,
I do think that your answer
is precisely what is required.
One has to pivot to local
players and stakeholders
and see how one can
reinforce the circumstances
that maybe without government support
or without long term sustainability,
just to tied communities over
at a time of tremendous crisis and stress.
So I've seen you do that,
so I wasn't surprised by your response
and quite the contrary,
I thought it was an inspiring response.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, and often like
and I'm sure you have the same experience
that often when you work
with community-based
organizations in weak states
or where the governance
systems are not that robust
when things stabilize
often it's the manpower
from these community-based organizations
and sometimes not always
it's their legitimization,
especially if the resolution
is towards the better state
of things in these situations.
And so again, it's not necessarily
bypassing the government,
it is leveraging what is available
and often community-based organizations,
if I may say, is a mechanism
for self-governance
that some communities use
to fill in some of those
gaps in services, et cetera.
And so there's this interesting,
but provocative, if I may
say so, question around,
what is the role or approach of the IRC
in challenging powers, such
as nations with veto powers
who are seemingly immune from sanctions
and other measures that you mentioned
in situations such as the crisis in Yemen.
But I would add so the
question was around Yemen,
but I would say there's
more than one situation
where this is the case.
- Well, look, I think our
role is always twofold,
one is to serve the people
'cause we have to abide by
the humanitarian principles
of impartiality independence
and the humanity
is very, very important,
neutrality as well.
But second, I think we
have to bear witness
and we have to speak about
what's actually happening
and if there are allies of the US
who are interfering in humanitarian
aid, we gotta say that.
Now, I'll be absolutely honest with you
without going into specifics,
there are places in the world
where it's too dangerous
for us to speak out
and that is a real danger.
In this emergency watch
list that I talked about,
that we launched for this year
and launched in December in a lecture
at the Council of Foreign Relations,
I made the case that we need
an independent office for the protection
of humanitarian access
because UN officials and NGOs
are in double jeopardy.
If we speak out, we can get kicked out
and we need some independent leadership
and some independent...
We could supply the information
but then it would be anonymized
so that it could then be used.
But I think those are
our two responsibilities,
we've gotta serve the people,
but we've also gotta speak,
not for them, but we've
gotta speak to what we see
and that's what we try to do.
I mean, we're doing
that on our Afghanistan,
I mean, we are very, very, very negative
about the current
international economic policy
towards Afghanistan,
even though we're a partner
of the US government in the US
and happy to partner
with them on the ground.
- Yeah, no, no, I think
that is the approach
that's how you thread the needle.
So I have two questions
and two final questions
then ultimate and the final
questions, related questions.
One from a student and the
other one from a faculty member
and you alluded to some part of it,
but I'll start with the student question
and you can take them together.
The question is many
in our audiences aspire
to be global health professionals
focused on humanitarian crises,
what advice can you share
for these individuals
that could inspire them?
And the second one is again related,
you mentioned that you are
the biggest impact evaluator,
which is very valuable
and sometimes knowing what
doesn't work is equally important
as figuring out what works.
You face a lot of difficult
challenges like this,
how does IRC and other
humanitarian agencies
prepare their staff to
face ethical challenges
and how do they partner with universities
in enhancing some of these
actions and capabilities
where both the partners can benefit
in terms of their mission?
- Right, I mean, on the first I think,
apply for jobs at the IRC.
I mean, most of the
jobs are for local hires
in the places that we work,
but we do have global hires as well,
but I think the best advice
is to get your boots dirty,
I wish I'd done that
when I was in my twenties
and spend time interna...
I mean, I spent time at
MIT that doesn't count
as international experience
really as a graduate student.
So I think get your boots
dirty on the ground,
doing research or seeing what works,
because I think that's
invaluable and your twenties
is the right out time to do it.
Probably your twenties and your sixties.
In respect to the second question,
I'm maybe not gonna answer
it as well as I should.
First of all, we have our
own ethical standards boards
and we have to sustain
our own ethical standards
that's important.
We don't do randomized control trials
of denying some people food
and giving other people food
and seeing what the consequences.
So we have to...
I mean, maybe that's a
too obvious an example,
but we have process to try
and adhere to high standards.
I think that my appeal
to you, would be that...
I mean, this really befuddles
me, I have to confess to you,
I know this is a public event,
so maybe, I'll think how I say this,
but I'm completely flummoxed
that a 41 billion sector
of the global economy finds
it so difficult to spend money
on evidence making it's completely crazy.
I mean, I thought eight years
ago when I joined the IRC
that we made outcomes,
evidence value for money and innovation,
RND our sort of washing line
or the spine is a better way
of putting it of our effort.
And I thought, well,
it's obvious at the time it
was $26 billion of spent,
I thought, well, of course
if I was a minister still,
first thing I'd do is say to the taxpayer,
well, sometimes we get things right
sometimes we get things wrong,
but we always put our money
behind what we think works
and what we think works
is not just by sticking
our finger in the air,
it's by doing proper evidence making
and if it then transpires
that the evidence shows it doesn't work,
well, we were following the evidence
and then it got updated.
It's very, very hard
to raise the for evidence
making, it's crazy
and so if you want a good thing
to come out of this seminar,
it would be a way for Yale
School of Public health and us
to raise a fund, to do
proper evidence making.
Because that's still short changed
in a completely shortsighted way
and it's absurd really
for our leadership team
to be presented with the question,
how much you put into evidence making
versus how much you put into programs.
I mean, that's a obvious
choice of really a bad kind
and I think that would be a
good thing to come out of this.
- Absolutely data is not distraction.
- Exactly.
- And it has some of it has some
of the highest return on investment
whenever it has to evaluated-
- Absolutely, it's obvious.
- So, that's great and
we'd be happy to follow up
on sort of things where-
- If you give us a bit
of the Yale endowment,
it earmarks some of the Yale endowment
for annual spend on evidence making.
- Yeah, absolutely give
me the checkbook there.
No, I'm just joking.
- That's I was told when I agreed to this.
- Yeah, no, I think going forward
that's what modern global
health should look like
and a lot of modern global
health looks like that
and a lot of modern humanitarian action
looks like that as well.
You don't have to withhold intervention
to get at the best practices,
you can look at natural experiments
as you were alluding to et cetera,
and sort of still do robust evaluations
and so on and so forth.
So on that note, I wanna thank you
for participating in
this conversation series.
Hopefully in the coming years,
we'll have the privilege to
have you take the train up
to our station and interact
with our students and faculty
over and break bread with
our community members
for a future event.
So it's been wonderful to have you here.
- Thank you very much.
- And thank you.
- Good night from London,
thank you very much
- Good night.